[Music]
control enforcement News Oh submitted by
Tiger lady pike a lady the Electoral
Commission wants to ban social media
trolls from voting how do they first of
all this is in the UK oh okay
Electoral Commission oh is it because
you could vote online so they're
thinking there's a lot of people there's
gonna go online and there's so many
trolls now they're just gonna fall for
like the most stupid politician escape
but yeah they're just saying that a lot
of troll has been threatening like
members of the Parliament and so they're
just saying like people like that should
not be able to vote that's pretty much
the logistic wait people that threaten
members of the Parliament shouldn't they
go to jail yeah but they're they're like
anonymous online trollers oh so they're
gonna get their own hackers to find out
who they are
well then really go into detail on how
they would do it is just this is just
something that's being considered thank
you
so this is just something that's being
proposed as it now but it's just
something interesting like if you would
actually ban social-media trolls yeah
cuz how do you know who Charlie Brown 65
is mmm-hmm no or dick cheese 196 and
it's so easy to pretend to be someone
else or like use someone else's identity
or like mask your IP or do all kinds of
[ __ ] like how are you gonna find out but
yeah they're just trying to reduce the
amount of abuse that politicians and
what constitutes as trolling well like
for instance this one a member of
parliament said that someone had
threatened to bomb her office another
one said that they would have a bottle
smashed on them things like that it's
not like a threat of terrorism if you
you threatened to bomb a place they can
go to jail for that yeah that's true
yeah I don't know how they're gonna find
all of them that's a lot of that's a lot
of resources it's gonna be really
expensive possibly not find anyone or
find out [ __ ] twelve-year-old kid
that's being dumb all right like if they
find the wrong person like I could
pretend to be to make an account all
that stuff and then let's you swatted
yeah
all the time hope you will pretend to be
you yeah it'll get some boring [ __ ] like
my name is Natalie I'm here from China
and I want some fun mm-hm
they're just trying to make money from
your likeness right I always get escorts
you should collect off of that [ __ ]
that's what I'm saying like oh my god
yeah you're free to use my photos give
me 20% Yeah right
you're also free to use my photos I get
no cut my photos if you get a date with
it you deserve it that's crazy dude it's
a rich old man's like I want to touch
that boy I don't know that's kind of
scary like now you can get in trouble
for things that you do and say online
yeah how many people are losing their
jobs well some people deserve it for
sure a lot of people actually do deserve
that if you're telling people in a bond
they're [ __ ] or whatever yeah but there
should be accountability yeah yeah who
are just blatantly racist on video I
like when they get fired hmm but like
since people can pretend to be you and
trick and and it's like that's the part
that I'm like oh [ __ ] how do they know
for sure for sure you know I wonder if
there's like any data or like
information that's attached to the
comment that you leave and like maybe
there's like some sort of IP address or
something to just make it to the source
yeah but then with people that troll
like that I'm pretty sure they use like
whatever backdoor [ __ ] I don't know what
about if the citizens are just pissed at
their politicians and they say [ __ ] like
off with his head I guess if there's
consequences and they wouldn't know I
mean like it's normal politics to kind
of have citizens pissed at the
politicians and say [ __ ] like that
because if there's a line between you're
not allowed to say anything or else we
incarcerate you that's that's
dictatorship yeah but then like if it's
I guess it's like if only if it's like
legit threatening yeah I feel like if
they voiced like oh I don't like how
these taxes are going over here I didn't
that's fine the winner out threatening
people that's probably where they're
gonna come down on you
well what about satire if people go I
hope he gets assassinated Kathy Griffin
yeah yeah like how she said was it Trump
yeah
filling up his head or whatever like
yeah it smells pretty graphic she
retracted her apology right I don't know
if she retracted
she's like I'm taking her back ya know
why she took him back why because she
got heat from the comedy world like why
why would you distinct to your [ __ ]
guns like in the comic world
everything's our free-for-all yeah I
think a lot of comments like you puss so
did she put her apology back out there
or take it I think she like she took it
back I think cuz she didn't she was like
that's right I shouldn't have to
apologize for the [ __ ] I think it's also
shocking cause it was Kathy Griffin I
don't I didn't I just never picked then
it's Kathy Griffin though out there I
didn't think she was that hardcore
she's pretty out there though she's like
strong yeah I thought she I thought she
was a primate I didn't think she was
gory in her comedy oh you're not gory
but she's super opinionated so I wasn't
surprising when I saw that from her but
it was more along the lines up for me
that's even too far for me but
everybody's moral compass is different
so I'm not really hate not I'm just more
like yeah don't touch that [ __ ] she lost
a lot a lot of brands a lot of money but
that's the price to pay if you want to
be too controversial that's like
what's-her-name was it it was a Sinead
O'Connor who tore up my picture at the
Pope
what this was 1990 something like she
tore up the picture of a pope on stage
and pretty much ruined your career
why does she turbo what did the Pope do
I know I don't know something like that
picture dude oh is that is that when the
Pope was you know licking buttholes of
[ __ ] yeah he was licking buttholes of
altar boys I think if okay you can
correct news playing the Blessed reach I
think she was on stage at a concert and
she said like table I don't know but she
tore the picture and everyone pretty
much like shunned her and later on it
came out that that Pope was a pedophile
somewhere career died for no reason she
was right yeah I think that was what it
was
that's insane yeah but you s like for
that that's like torching the whole
catholic' or Protestant religion yeah if
you do that that's like tearing up a
picture of Jesus Christ
yeah and then you know if she has like a
huge religious following they're just
gonna be like I can't touch them do you
guys feel like the way the whole
internet climate is changing where
everyone's either like way too sensitive
with whatever's being said or like way
too vulgar yeah like way too far in
there
no for sure but it's going like further
and further this we've got politics to
like it's getting really polarizing
politics is like will star now dude yeah
there's no it's only about entertainment
there's like that legitimacy that I saw
when I was younger when it came to like
the election or any type of policy I
don't know what's what everything's
sensationalized to the max so it's like
if you go on like Joe was saying before
it's like you're on California Facebook
it's way different from Texas is
Facebook [ __ ] you know and it's very
evident cuz I've cut this cousin who
lives in Texas and he's just all about
like red [ __ ] you know I mean like he's
just gonna go you know and I'm like but
that's different from the stuff that I'm
getting so he's like super hardcore
Republican now hates like any kind of
left-wing liberal stuff and he's just
like posting all this propaganda now you
mentioned to him I was like yo like you
know chill off on that stuff a little
bit he goes well this is what's
happening I was like bro you can't just
read three sentences from article and
automatically believe it like do you
even like go in and research it how can
you be so staunch on an idea when you
haven't even looked at the other side
but people don't care and they're also
lazy about their education now they read
the title like oh I know we do and they
move on and they repost it yeah
so sad I don't like that [ __ ] man okay
we've been watching the show comrades
detective words about like communist
Bucharest
there's Budapest on this book or
Bucharest Romania so this takes place in
Romania and then it's dubbed by Joseph
gordon-levitt and Magic Mike was insane
Channing Tatum yeah that guy so anyways
this whole show it's like anti
capitalism so the way like they paint
Americans it's like they're just trying
to whatever so they show got a lot of
hate from both sides like people from
the right and left oh yeah
because they're both capitalists at the
end of the day we're america so yeah but
they don't really get what the show was
trying to do and so Joseph gordon-levitt
was saying that it's not about like
anti-communist or pro-communist it's not
really about that it's looking at like
tribalism and the way how people are
just so obsessed with belonging to one
side yeah like we have to be on separate
sides for everything yeah why can't
everyone be everything yeah exactly
well it's also the like beef base
culture we're in like all the algorithms
and whatever we like it just keeps
popping up on our feet
so if you go on YouTube if you go on
Facebook if you go on all these things
right and if you're constantly watching
videos that are maybe like feminists or
whatever then everything that comes up
is gonna be that so you don't get to see
the other side you don't get to see
opinions of Fox News or whatever because
you're watching all the liberal media
and you're it's the same thing as they
want you to click things that they think
you're gonna like but then this is the
result of it cuz it's like it happens
with the consumerism like with Amazon
they know you like I like weapons they
know I like you know I like these kind
of clothes or whatever so it's always
gonna popular female clothes basically
exactly so on my Instagram like even
though it has nothing to do with Amazon
boom somehow they know that hey I was
just looking at that three days ago on
Amazon are you sure you don't want to
buy it but that's the same with the news
on Facebook everything so people's minds
and worlds are being shaped their
perception is being shaped based off of
what they already liked and what they're
not being exposed to new ideas so I
think that's the biggest issue in
creating the polar eight on your horizon
world yeah because me I study dictators
I said you know you know what I've been
who I've been watching recently is
Duarte
the Filipino president do tech dude yeah
the only thing I've heard of him is like
he's like the Filipino Trump he's crazy
this and that and the more I watch him
speak the more I'm like this guy's
actually dope yeah I really like him my
friends who are actually in the military
actually don't mind him cuz he said that
it's such a problem over there that he's
the only one that's actually doing
anything about it exactly you know so
he's and then my friends just like this
is the only way sometimes this is the
only way so I kind of see it on his side
too but I also see em on like it's hard
because number one we don't live in that
country we don't know what goes on and
that's exactly what it is yeah it's not
up to America to be the world police
yeah that's their world we don't know
what's going on in there and also to
life that's what it's funny cuz that's
what he literally said in an interview
he goes why the [ __ ] should I care about
what America thinks about my country he
goes you don't know how impoverished it
is over here he goes I'm the only person
making a difference he goes
what how do you get to look over there
and tell us what to do you don't live
here I don't know if I agree or disagree
with that but it's more like that's true
though that's a fact
we don't live that we don't know what's
going on so I don't know I don't believe
in like just killing people but well my
friend says like one of those things
like kill kill a few save many kind of
thing you know and it somehow changes
things a little bit more he's like
that's the only way you can possibly do
it sucks but you have to I mean I think
what it is is we have a double standard
because we b-bomb in places all the time
and there's kids and normal citizens
getting [ __ ] bombed up for hundreds
of years ever since that you know we
decided to be world police but then we
point the finger at the Filipino
president and whoever that wants to use
the same tactic and I'm just like and
he's not like Trumpy because he didn't
come from money he came from no money
yeah yeah that's true he didn't come
from money he's just a regular guy yeah
hey what's up guys thanks for watching
we are going to regularly start posting
content on the JK films Instagram so
make sure you follow us there our last
video click over here